وجودك معنا نختم سؤال مطلوب من زميلتنا
رشا نبيل كيف ترد على كل من يقول انه محمد
صلاح يمكن ان ينتهي رياضيا خصوصا انه اصبح
الهدف التاريخي لليفربول طبعا محمد صلاح
في كل مره يثبت بانه لم ينتهي محمد صلاح
خلنا ناخذ التصور العام مولود في بسيون في
مصر
والان هو هداف لفريق ليفربول الذي تاسس
عام 1892 بطل دوري ابطال اوروبا ست مرات
منها واحده مع محمد صلاح يعني الاستيعاب
ما يقدمه محمد صلاح يجب ان نتذكر بان
الهداف التاريخي السابق مع منتخب انجلترا
قبل
يعني اسماء كنا واحنا صغار نحط البوستر
تبعها ونشوفها على التلفزيون والان واحد
منا محمد صلاح ربما نشعر بقيمه ما قدمه من
انجازات تاريخيه بعد اعتزاله لانه للاسف
الان في الثلاثينات من عمره يمكن خمس او
ست سنوات
نحتاج نحتاج الى التوقف والنظر مليا بما
قدمه من انجازات ليس فقط في تسجيل الاهداف
وايضا في صناعتها دائما الناس بتروح على
الاهداف مبارح سجل هدفين وصنع هدفين يعني
يحتاج ربما الى وقت اطول لتقييم ما قدمه
صلاح بشكل موضوعي ومنطقي من مجرد الرد
الفعل لدينا الان ربما بسبب
امور اخرى ليست متعلقه باداء داخل الملعب
لكن صلاح هو تاريخ